You even called them scams
of ways to see theater.
This was nice -- "I haven't used
since I was an undergrad.
You go to the box office
and confidently say your nam
when they ask.
When they don't see your name,
just say,
'Ex-board member invited
my dad and I.
They will find a ticket.'"
[ Laughter ]
-I mean, I hate to say this,
but I scammed
a lot of theaters
in California...
-Yeah.
-...and New York
and Chicago in my, like,
rush to want to see theate
in my early 20s.
-This is another one I like --
"Text a rich friend,
'Oh, my God,
have you heard about
this insane show "Slave Play"?
Everyone's saying it's amazing.'
Then send them a link
and they will say,
'Should we go?', and then
they will buy the tickets.
-Yes.
[ Laughter, applause ]
-One, I hope people do that,
and, two, I think it's great
that people should get in there,
and they should see the play
and it's worth $39.
It is worth all the other ticket
prices as well, and --
-Listen, I'm looking
at you right now.
-Yeah.
-Because you said you thin
people should text
their rich friends.
-Yeah.
-You are rich.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I'm in this space.
-Yeah.
-If someone tweets you tonight
that they want to see
"Slave Play,"
will you buy them a ticket
-Yeah.
-You will?
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Okay. Okay.
I didn't plan this scam.
-Okay, great.
-This is a scam.
-I can't believe
I brought up the scams
and then you scammed me!
-Yes.
[ Laughter ]
-So I can't sit here now
and be like, "I didn't kno
he was a scammer."
There are tweets! Argh!
It would be my honor.
-Okay, great.
Tweet at --
-Let's say the first 10 people
to tweet me about this,
I will get tickets
to "Slave Play."
-Will you get them premium
tickets?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-You will?
-I'll give the first 10 people
to --
[ Cheering continues ]
You know what? What an honor
to be played by you, sir.
Jeremy O. Harris, everybody.